dann nehmen wir platz genommen der
präsident des robert koch instituts
professor dr lothar wieler und ganz
außen professor christian drosten der
direktor des instituts für virologie an
der charité berlin auf ein sie ein
herzliches bekommen
bevor wir anfangen eine übliche
vorbemerkung da die pressekonferenz live
übertragen wird beziehungsweise gefunden
die bundespressekonferenz ist keine
institution der bundesregierung sondern
ein
unabhängiger verein von journalistinnen
und journalisten die aus berlin über die
bundespolitik berichten unsere aufgabe
ist es pressekonferenzen zu veranstalten
damit unsere mitgliedschaft die
öffentlichkeit besser informieren kann
das als vorbemerkung und jetzt haben sie
das wort bitte schön ja vielen dank
handy wahrnehmen meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren
mal bei ihnen ganz herzlich bedanken
dass sie wieder dazu gelegenheit haben
hier in dem in ihrem forum vortragen zu
dürfen
ich habe neben herrn villa der uns die
aktuellen zahlen und
bewegungen in japan haben wird heute
herrn professor drosten gebeten uns
heute zu ergänzen und zu verstärken so
dass er uns auch einen ausblick liefern
kann er ist heute da in seiner funktion
als einzel experte nicht für den
expertenrat wir tauschen wir uns seit
beginn der pandemie sehr regelmäßig
außen ich möchte diese gelegenheit auch
nutzen um mich nochmal öffentlich auch
für diese unterstützung und hilfe zu
bedanken von der ich auch schon sehr
lange profitiere und verteilt sich froh
dass worte mit dabei sind ich wurde kurz
etwas also zum stand der pandemie aus
der sicht des
bundesgesundheitsministeriums berichten
gekommen jetzt langsam in dieser lage
hinein wo wir also mit von als die
großem abstand dominierende
variante sei variante bekämpfen müssen
die modellierung des robert koch
instituts hatten einen verlauf wie wir
ihnen jetzt beobachten ungefähr auch
vorher gesagt wir sehen dass also die
kontakt maßnahmen die wir in deutschland
noch am platz haben wirken wir haben ja
ungefähr nur 50 prozent so viele
kontakte im moment wie im vor
pandemischer
zeitalter und diese kontakt begrenzungen
für uns dazu dass wir in deutschland
nicht die kurze
verdoppelte auch mikron variante haben
die wir in vielen anderen europäischen
ländern sehen die
top verdopplung ist sogar etwas
gestreckt die sie lag aber vor wenigen
wochen noch bei ungefähr viereinhalb
tagen durfte jetzt sich auf eine woche
zu bewegen bei ungefähr 66 anhalt tagen
somit die maßnahmen die wir ergriffen
haben wirken dazu zählen die zwei geben
regel beispielsweise im handel die also
regeln die wir geschaffen haben am
arbeitsplatz oder auch also im
öffentlichen personennahverkehr die
kontakt begrenzungen im privaten umfeld
und dazu kommt jetzt zusätzlich die 2g
plus regelungen die wir bei der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz vor einer
woche beschlossen haben worauf läuft das
ganze hinaus deshalb machen wir das
deshalb streben wir überhaupt an dass
sich die verdopplung zeit verlängert
durch die maßnahmen die wir machen da
der hintergrund ist der wir wollen aus
der sonst erwarten steilen wand der
infektionszahlen wenn möglich einen
hügel machen oder wenn sich das nicht
vermeiden dass es an der wand ist was
sie waren nicht so hoch ist dass es das
strategische ziel der bundesregierung
was dahinter steht es wenn uns das
gelänge hätten wir weniger sterbefälle
zu beklagen und weniger schwere verläufe
und weniger lang offizielle weniger
komplikationen die wir nicht wirklich
abschätzen können somit das ziel ist es
das unvermeidbare nämlich die steigende
zahl der omicron fälle so zu strecken
und so zu reduzieren dass wir mit einer
möglichst geringen zahl von opfern durch
die novelle hinweg kommen und von dem
was wir bisher sehen zeigen die
maßnahmen die wir ergriffen haben auch
die ungefähr zu erwartende wirkung
trotzdem gibt es keinen grund zu
entwarnung die daten die wir bisher
vorliegen haben die zeigen dass die
omikron variante weniger gefährlich ist
als zum beispiel die data variante diese
daten sind auf deutschland nicht eins zu
eins übertragen ich habe heute morgen
auch mit andros noch mal über eine
studie gesprochen die sehr bedeutsam ist
aus kalifornien an der auch der
epidemiologe mal clips von der
arbeitsbühne of public es tage genommen
hat wo man sehen kann im vergleich zu
den teils in dieser methodik guten
studie zu sehen dass die omikron
varianten ungefähr halb so gefährlich
ist was also einweisungen ins
krankenhaus angeht und nur ein viertel
so gefährlich ist was anpassungen auf
die intensivstation angeht aber in
diesen studien auch in dieser
spezifischen studie die von der
berkeley-universität gemacht worden ist
muss man beachten
es sind in diesen studien in der regel
weniger ältere menschen die infiziert
waren und ausgewertet worden sind und
wir haben in deutschland die
sondersituation dass wir eine besonders
hohe quote von ungeimpften haben bei der
älteren bevölkerung die darüber hinaus
noch viele risikofaktoren haben das ist
die sondersituation mit der wir in
deutschland um chor umgehen müssen daher
sind die nachrichten die wir bekommen
und die mir auch immer wieder
vorgetragen werden ist das ganze jetzt
nicht vorbei mit der mikrowelle diese
nachrichten sind auf deutschland
wahrscheinlich so nicht übertragbar und
ich warne vor dem gedanken dass wir in
deutschland andere durch solche
akzeptieren können die zahl der opfer
die wir dann beklagen müssten ist
ungewiss ist sicherlich zu hoch und es
würde auch nicht dazu führen dass wir
danach ein einen schutz vor weiteren
varianten hätten denn das ist von der
stadt gehabt omikron infektion nicht
abzuleiten und eher unwahrscheinlich
ich komme zum schluss meiner kurzen
einführungen also ich glaube dass wir
jetzt in ein schwieriges fahrwasser
kommen wir werden viele menschen
mit infektion versorgen müssen die
krankenhäuser werden an ihrer
belastungsgrenze kommen die labore
werden an ihrer belastungsgrenze kommen
wir haben eine neue cola schutzmaßnahmen
ausnahmen verordnung heute im bundesrat
beschlossen dort ist die quarantäne und
die installationszeit auf sieben tage
gekürzt worden diejenigen die aus dem
medizinischen bereich kommend und in
isolation sind müssen einen pcr nachweis
erbringen dass sie nicht mehr ansteckend
sind gemessen an dem ct wert 30 damit
wir diese pcr-test nun auch durchführen
können habe ich gestern veranlasst dass
wir diejenigen die aus diesen bereichen
kommen und eine freie testung mit den
pcr benötigen priorisiert werden bei den
labor- und so dass wir sicherstellen
kann dass diejenigen die aus dem
medizinischen bereich kommen und an der
pcr test und benötigen die pcr testung
auch dann bekommen wenn die tcr
kapazität
ausgereizt ist oder überlastet sein
durfte schließlich also wir führen die
buskampagne weiter fort ich bin mit dem
booster tempo insgesamt zufrieden wir
werden es aber noch einmal beschleunigen
wenn es uns gelingt die also wand oder
die bälle so zu verlangsamen dass wir
das poster tempo nutzen können um
möglichst viele zu ostern die sonst
schwer erkannt werden
dann ist unsere strategie aufgegangen
die strategie war ja von anfang an wir
verlangsamen die welle wir strecken die
wir und postern in dieser zeit so viele
menschen wie möglich um diejenigen die
dann also sonst infiziert worden während
vor der infektion zu schützen und wenn
sie sich infizieren dann von schwerer
krankheit zu schützen das ist teil
unserer strategie und dafür ist der
impfstoff da ich habe seit amtsbeginn
55 millionen dosen booster impfstoff für
die bundes für die bundesregierung
erworben wir können hat damit jeder
booster impfung durchführen die in
deutschland sinnvollerweise gemacht
werden könnte herzlichen dank herr
lauterbach
und tag meine damen und herren die
omikron welle sieht sich weiter auf und
das mit einer dynamik wie wir sie in
dieser pandemie bislang noch nicht
gesehen haben es ist nämlich genau das
eingetroffen was befürchtet wurde im
moment macht omikron bundesweit schon
mehr als 70 prozent aller neuinfektionen
aus nikon dominiert das
infektionsgeschehen in deutschland und
wir gehen davon aus dass ist delta in
den nächsten tagen auch vollständig
verdrängen wird
die fallzahlen sind so hoch wie nie und
sie werden auch weiter steigen in dieser
woche haben die gesundheitsämter
erstmals mehr als 80.000 fälle pro tag
gemeldet innerhalb eines tages und
gestern war diese zahl sogar über 90.000
es gibt im moment geschätzt mindestens
800.000 aktive fälle das ist also knapp
ein prozent der bevölkerung und das
heißt dass einer von 100 menschen in
deutschland jetzt in dem moment mit saas
kauf 2 infiziert ist und das sind ja nur
die fälle von denen wir aus dem
meldesystem kenntnis haben fast jeder
vierte pcr test in der letzten woche war
positiv und
aktuell liegt die sieben tage
hospitalisierung inzidenz adjustiert bei
rund 7 und damit ist sie noch
vergleichsweise niedrig wir hatten die
höchste etwa bei 15 um weihnachten herum
aber die tendenz steigt wieder das heißt
diese vergleichsweise niedrigen zahlen
sind auch keinen grund zur entwarnung
auch weil zu beginn hauptsächlich
jüngere menschen
infiziert worden sind und wir wissen
dass in den nächsten wochen zunehmend
eben auch ältere menschen betroffen sein
werden der anteil der patienten auf den
intensivstationen geht im moment weiter
zurück auch die zahl der todesfälle in
verbindung mit cupid 19 ist noch nicht
wieder angestiegen das wird sich aber
ändern
selbst eine infektion durch micon
insgesamt milder verlaufen durch die
masse an infektion müssen wir uns leider
darauf einstellen dass auch die zahl der
hospitalisierungen und der todesfälle
natürlich wieder steigen wird
mit nikon und in massiv steigenden
fallzahlen treten wir tatsächlich in
eine neue phase der pandemie ein die
reinen fallzahlen werden weniger
entscheidend sein wichtiger ist wie
viele menschen schwer an cupid 19
erkranken und wie stark das
gesundheitssystem dann belastet sein
wird bei der masse an infektion müssen
wir damit rechnen dass die
infektionszahlen über die meldedaten
schlichtweg weniger gut erfasst werden
das hat verschiedene gründe mit
steigender tendenz wird die unter
erfassung größer mehr infizierte ohne
oder nur mit geringen symptomen gehen
gar nicht mehr erst zum test auch wegen
begrenzter laborkapazitäten wird nur
noch ein teil der infizierten pcs
getestet und daneben auch als fall
gezählt und gemeldet werden außerdem
sind die gesundheitsämter so belastet
dass sie nicht mehr alle kontaktpersonen
identifizieren oder daten zu den fällen
nach recherchieren können das tun sie
jetzt schon kaum noch um das klar zu
sagen auch der diagnosen meldet vollzug
wird natürlich größer da durch das heißt
wir gehen davon aus dass die sieben tage
inzidenz sieben tage aus vitalisierung
incidents und auch die angaben zum
impfstatus am höhepunkt der welle
weniger vollständig sein werden als das
momentan der fall ist das sehen wir auch
teilweise jetzt schon aber
wir werden die situation trotzdem
weiterhin gut abschätzen können erstens
bilden die meldedaten die trends im
infektionsgeschehen natürlich weiterhin
ab zweitens haben wir noch andere janes
systeme die die meldedaten ergänzen zb
das intensiv register die tests zahl
erfassung und vor allem aber die sind
römische und virologische surveillance
von atemwegsinfektionen diese sind
gibt es schon sehr lange darüber wird
zum beispiel erfasst wie verbreitet
atemwegserkrankungen in der bevölkerung
sind welche atemwegs viren in der
bevölkerung zirkulieren wie viele
menschen mit welchen atemwegsinfektionen
ins krankenhaus kommen und behandelt
werden müssen
das ist aktuell besonders wichtig daher
auch die influenza zunehmend zirkuliert
all diese ergebnisse werden auch schon
lange im coebad 19 wochen bericht
dargestellt sie ergänzen sich
gegenseitig und werden gemeinsam von uns
betrachtet und ausgewertet und diese
gesamtschau macht es in dieser phase der
pandemie möglich die häufigkeit schwerer
erkrankungen die app ideologische lage
und auch ihre dynamik weiteren gut
bewerten zu können
nikon hat die lage verändert und kugelt
19 breitet sich so stark in deutschland
aus wie nie aber es ist in unser aller
interesse ansteckungen so gut es geht zu
verhindern die gründe hat minister
lauterbach eben sehr eindrücklich noch
einmal vermittelt wir haben die
werkzeuge und wir können infektionen
vermeiden wenn auch nicht jede infektion
aber jede infektion die wir verhindern
trägt zur bewältigung der welle 1 bei
und auch dazu das gesundheitssystem zu
entlasten wenn sie einer akuten
atemwegsinfektion haben sollte
schnellstmöglichst abgeklärt werden ob
es sich dabei um kuwait 19 handeln oder
nicht bitte bleiben sie zu hause um eine
gott tagen auf weitere person zu
verhindern viele infektionen finden aber
auch zu hause statt wenn in ihrem
haushalt eine kurve 19 test positiv
könnten sie überlegen ob das tragen
einer maske im eigenen haushalt für sie
eine option ist
denn die maske reduziert eine weitere
übertragung
regelmäßiges lüften muss natürlich
trotzdem stattfinden
und wirklich mein dringender appell wenn
sie noch nicht geimpft sind dann bitte
tun sie es jetzt impfungen verhindern
nicht unbedingt eine ansteckung das ist
wahr aber sie sind der beste schutz vor
einem schweren verlauf die mehrheit der
menschen die wegen co wird 19 auf
intensivstationen kommen die ist
ungeimpft das zeigen nicht nur die daten
zu impfen durchbrüchen aus dem
meldesystem die wir wöchentlich
berichten sondern bestätigen auch die
neuen daten aus dem intensiv register
die wir gestern veröffentlicht haben
impfungen helfen also eine überlastung
des gesundheitssystems und alle anderen
gesellschaftlichen systeme vorzubeugen
lassen sie sich impfen und auffrischen
sie schützen sie sich
so schützen wir uns alle auch für
schwere erkrankungen wir sind es auch
den ärzten den ärztinnen und unserem
pflegepersonal einfach schuldig lassen
sie uns gemeinsam auch diese welle in
den griff bekommen
herzlichen dank professor wille
professor thorsten
hallo danke hinten nach unseren regeln
zu sprechen die maske abnehmen aber sie
muss ja
erstmal verständlichkeit etwas höher
dankeschön genau ok also es ist glaube
ich im moment eine ganz schwierige zeit
zu kommunizieren also ganz viel wird
missverstanden
es gibt viele gemischte botschaften die
in der öffentlichkeit nicht gut genug
erklärt sind zum beispiel dieses virus
ist tatsächlich milder in seinem verlauf
aber es gibt ja viel zu viele fälle so
dass dann eben diese dieser gewinn über
die milden verläufe wieder ausgelöscht
wird weil es zu viele fälle sind
wir haben positive und negative
botschaften die sie in den beiden
vorträgen hier schon genannt worden
beispielsweise sehr gut dass wir in
deutschland eine längere verdopplung
zeit haben als in anderen ländern wo das
initial alles beschrieben wurde wie
schnell das geht also diese omikron wand
die ist entstanden in ländern in denen
vorher kaum wirklich kontakt maßnahmen
noch in kraft waren volle pubs
beispielsweise die bilder aus england
sind ja bekannt
das sind war natürlich bei uns anders
weil wir ja im herbst schon probleme mit
delta hatten und dann einige
bundesländer sehen starke maßnahmen
einführen mussten und mit diesen
maßnahmen ist dann omikron gekommen und
konnte sich nicht so schnell verbreiten
also diese unterschiedlichkeit die muss
man verstehen
dann haben wir leider eine schlechte
grundvoraussetzungen also das war jetzt
eine gute die schlechte ist wir haben
diese im pflücke in deutschland das sind
3 millionen über 60-jährige die gar
nicht geimpft sind und wahrscheinlich
auch noch keine infektion hatten und man
könnte diese zahl erhöhen denn man weiß
inzwischen man braucht für dieses
omikron virus wirklich auch die dritte
impfung um richtig geschützt zu sein und
das sind dann fast neun millionen in
dieser altersgruppe und das ist ja die
gefährdete altersgruppe und wir haben
auch so über 8 millionen bei den
erwachsenen über 18 auf die das zutrifft
und das ist nicht gut
ich glaube die schwierigste doppel
botschaft über die wir vielleicht
sprechen können ist wir werden ja nicht
auf dauer über alle paar monate die
gesamte bevölkerung wieder nach impfen
können um damit eine bevölkerungs
immunität oder ein gemeinschafts schutz
wie man das auch immerhin ausdrücken
will zu erhalten das geht nicht das
heißt irgendwann muss dieses virus auch
in der bevölkerung infektionen setzen
und das virus selbst muss die immunität
der menschen immer wieder sagen wir mal
updaten das ist etwas das ist eine eine
generelle weisheit in der
infektionsepidemiologie also dass da
können wir nichts gegen machen
die frage ist nur können wir das in
deutschland schon tun also in ländern
wie südafrika und so weiter sehr viele
infektionen schon gewesen sind auch zu
einem preis da ist dieser prozess weiter
fortgeschritten dieses erwerben einer
immer wieder durch das virus upgedatet
bevölkerungs immunität wir wissen aber
im moment nicht ob wir uns das in
deutschland leisten können angesichts
der im flügge das ist tatsächlich unser
größtes hindernis dabei und das kann
kaum jemand wirklich voraussagen es gibt
zwar ein paar klinische studien die
sagen wie auch die dritte oder die
zweite impfung gegen schweren verlauf
schützt und jetzt könnte man anfangen zu
rechnen wie viel zweit und dritt gifte
haben wir wie viele leute haben wir dann
aber da hört es wirklich auf also an der
stelle kann kein seriöser modellierer
noch irgendetwas voraussagen da sind wir
ein bisschen im blindflug also das ist
die schwierigste doppel botschaft im
moment dass wir es muss irgendwann
laufen aber vielleicht darf es das jetzt
noch nicht während es in anderen ländern
schon dazu kommt so jetzt wahrscheinlich
die zweit schwierigste doppel botschaft
ist es gibt relativ viele infektionen
bei geimpften und das wird in der
öffentlichkeit zum teil absichtlich und
zum teil aus unkenntnis falsch
dargestellt so als wäre es ja jetzt dann
komplett sinnlos geworden sich überhaupt
noch zu impfen das ist ja auch hier in
beiden vorträgen betont worden nein das
ist es nicht man muss vielleicht bilde
dafür benutzen und dazu wäre es ganz gut
sich mal das virus anzuschauen das würde
ich gerne einmal kurz machen das virus
dass wir jetzt vor uns haben ist eine
immun ist kämpfer rente was heißt das
das heißt erst mal was wenn wir das
vergleichen mit dem anderen virus das
was wir vorher hatten das waren fitness
varianten also die servieren die sind
einfach besser in ihrer replikation
geworden dadurch dass sie sich besser an
den menschen ohne ansicht der immunität
angepasst haben also zum beispiel an die
atemwege besser angepasst sie müssen
sich das vorstellen so eine fitness
variante das ist wie wenn sie ein auto
haben und dann schauen sie ein anderes
auto an das selbe modell hat aber einen
größeren motor kann schneller fahren
dieses virus hier ist aber jetzt eine
immun ist help variante die immunität in
der bevölkerung ist für so ein virus so
was wie ein unwegsames gelände stellen
sie sich in sandweg vor voller matsch
und
jetzt sehen sie da ist ein auto das
fährt schneller als ein anderes und sie
überlegen woran könnte das liegen und
wenn sie genau hinschauen dann sehen sie
dieses auto das hat eigentlich gar
keinen größeren motor das hat breitere
reifen das kann über diesen match besser
drüberfahren mit einem gleich starken
motor und das ist glaube ich im moment
ein bisschen das omikron virus in
unserer bevölkerung wir haben so eine
immunität in allen bevölkerungen das
virus und dass das zeigen
wissenschaftliche daten immer mehr hat
aber von seiner inneren verbreitungs
fähigkeit von seiner ps stärke im
eigentlich gar keinen vorteil zu dem was
vorher da war das ist ein auto mit einem
gleich großen motor einer breiteren
reifen für den sandweg und wir sind auf
einem sandweg wenn sie beide autos auf
die autobahn setzen dann sehen sie die
sind weiterhin gleich schnell vielleicht
hat sogar das eine mit den breiteren
reifen kleinen nachteile auf der
autobahn weil es nicht so gut vorwärts
kommt die reifen machen mehr reibung und
dieses beispiel lässt sich tatsächlich
auch übertragen denn das ist eigentlich
was sie sehen wenn sie sich diese
durchbruchs in vergleichen die gar nicht
geimpft sind dann sehen sie keinen
großen unterschied das ist eine gute
neuigkeit wir können vielleicht so ein
bisschen davon ausgehen dass dieses
virus deswegen besser kontrollierbar ist
in seiner geschwindigkeit das ist was
wir sehen hier bei uns in deutschland
längere generation längere verdopplung
zeit dieses virus ist in sich gar nicht
stärken wenn wir aber jetzt eben auf
diesen sandweg sind dann sehen wir
dieses virus kommt eigentlich besser
vorwärts obwohl es ihm gleich starken
motor hat ich weiß nicht ob dieses
beispiel nachvollziehbar ist so und
jetzt wäre es eben falsch zu sagen dass
dieser sandweg nicht existiert also das
nicht geimpft wurde der sandweg bremst
jedes auto ab die impfung bremst jedes
virus ab das ist ganz entscheidend sich
das klar zu machen und was wir mit der
impfung machen es wir machen immer mehr
macho auf diesen sandweg drauf bis das
auto irgendwann stecken bleibt dann kann
sich das auto nicht mehr verbreiten wir
haben inzwischen gelernt wir kriegen
keine herdenimmunität bei diesen tieren
das heißt das auto wird sich immer
weiter durch kämpfen aber das wird
irgendwann ganz schön langsam werden und
dann sind wir im endemischen zustand so
und diesen endemischen zustand das
erwarten wir schon den werden wir bis
ende des jahres schon entweder erreicht
haben oder wir sind praktisch da das ist
glaube ich wo jetzt im moment so die
große spekulation ist wie wird
eigentlich der nächste winter denn klar
ist gegen ostern wird es wieder wärmer
poster kampagne läuft zwei effekte die
eindeutig dazu beitragen werden dass die
verbreitung geringer werden wird von der
ganzen problematik da können wir uns
darauf verlassen
jetzt ist nur die frage
reicht der atem bis dahin können wir mit
der booster kampagne schnell genug
nachholen und wie geht es dann im sommer
weiter sommer wird es so sein wir werden
natürlich wieder ein ganz offenes
gesellschaftliches leben haben können
wird omicron infektionen geben das
wissen wir weil in südafrika bei einer
sehr gut immunisierten bevölkerung dort
im sommer weiter omikron infektionen da
sind das wird bei uns auch so sein
vielleicht wird uns das auch nicht so
stark stören wenn wir weitermachen mit
der immunisierung und dann im nächsten
winter das ist das entscheidende wie
geht es da weiter haben wir dann genug
immunität erreicht und ich glaube in der
alten bevölkerung in deutschland
brauchen wir dann zwei sachen das eine
ist wir müssen wie bei einer influenza
saison auch vorher nochmal die
gefährdeten die älteren die
grunderkrankung mit einer booster im
funk zum herbst versorgen und jetzt gibt
es aber in diesem jahr wahrscheinlich
eine spezialität dieses omikron virus
das ist nebenbei auch noch ein anderer
serotyp davon gehe ich im moment aus
viele biologen gehen darf moment von aus
das heißt wir werden wahrscheinlich auch
noch mal bei der impfung nach steuern
müssen es wird eine angepasste impfung
geben müssen und wir werden
möglicherweise eben dann ab dem zweiten
quartal große teile bevölkerung
vielleicht sogar alle noch einmal mit
einer update impfung gegen omikron
versehen müssen damit wir beide diese
verbreitete impfung haben gegen beide
typen also gegen das neue virus omikron
und gegen alle bis hierher bis dahin
vorhandenen viren die zu einem anderen
ehemaligen serotypen gehört gehören also
diese beiden immunität brauchen wir die
überlappen sich weitgehend da der
schweren krankheit ist der schutz
gewährleistet aber bei den übertragungs
schutz und dem schutz gegen die milde
krankheit brauchen wir beide sorten von
schutz und darauf müssen wir uns
einstellen das müssen wir vorbereitet
und auch hier wieder komme ich nochmal
zum abschluss auf diejenigen zurück die
sich bisher nicht haben impfen lassen
diese personen werden dann
möglicherweise jetzt mit einem omikron
virus in kontakt kommen sich infizieren
für hoffentlich einen milden verlauf
bekommen nur können die sich jetzt
dadurch nicht unbedingt auf dauer drauf
fällt lassen dass ein delta ähnliches
virus also ein ursprünglicher
serotyp nicht auch wieder zurückkommt
damit müssen wir rechnen
und dass diese personen dann dagegen
wieder im nächsten winter gar keinen
schutz haben das heißt die haben dann
nur diese eine seite die eine den einen
teil der immunität das ist auch eine
sehr schwierige botschaft in der
öffentlichkeit also diese drei
schwierigen botschaften habe ich jetzt
hier angesprochen also das virus muss
irgendwann laufen wir wissen nicht ob
wird uns das schon leisten können das
zweite eben diese wahrnehmung bei den
geimpften gibt es doch ganz schön viele
infektionen ja auf dem matschigen weg
fährt jedes auto irgendwie auch ein
bisschen weiter und das mit den breiten
reifen bisschen schneller hat aber
nichts zu bedeuten auf die motorkraft
und auch nicht das nicht grundsätzlich
auf einem schlamm weg ein autonomer
langsamer fährt als auf der autobahn
wäre das verkennt der verkehr kann auch
genauso gut dann verkennen dass die
impfungen wirken also das ist dann jedem
ein anheimgestellt das ist dann wirklich
ignoranz soll die die letzte botschaft
eben die ich da erklärt habe ist dass
mit dem serotyp das ist auch vielleicht
für diejenigen die wissenschaftlich
jetzt nicht so gewohnt sind über solche
dinge nachzudenken noch mal schwieriger
zu verstehen vielleicht hilft es bei der
influenza kennen wir das auch da müssen
wir ja immer mal die impfung auffrischen
so eine situation haben wir jetzt
herzlichen dank professor thorsten dann
kommen wir zu fragen ich habe schon mehr
als 15 fragesteller insofern ähnlich
noch mal in aller regel eine frage eine
zusatzfrage und die erste hat herr
heinrich dass die anderen patzen ich
würde auch gleich eine nachfrage noch
anmelden lade wachposten sie haben jetzt
alle drei von diesen doppelt botschaften
gesprochen und von der nach wie vor
bestehenden gefahr und von den kontakt
produktionen die schon gibt andererseits
beobachten der beobachter in vielen
städten das ist die kontakte weiterhin
gibt dass die lokale voll sind dass sich
weiterhin sehr viele menschen im
östlichen raum treffen die mobilität ist
weiter sehr groß ist es aus ihrer sicht
im aktuellen
verantwortbar roder muss dann auch mehr
geschehen und das zu reduzieren
ich
fange ich vielleicht also zunächst
einmal muss man den erfolg würdigen uns
ist es gelungen die verdopplung zeit der
omicron variante zu strecken und wir
haben daher deutlich weniger also fälle
pro tag zu beklagen auch immer zu viele
als andere länder und man muss so eine
strategie auch quasi durchhalten können
somit also glaube ich dass wir im moment
maßvoll vorgehen aber wenn tatsächlich
die fallzahlen deutlich steigen sollten
und sie kamen in einer situation hinein
wo wir auch also eine überlastung zu
schützen der medizinischen versorgung
erwarten müssen oder werden auch sehen
dass wir mehr schwer erkrankte haben im
moment sind ja die zahl derjenigen die
intensivstation für kurve behandelt
werden müssen aber wenn das sich ändern
sollte dann muss natürlich mit anderen
maßnahmen gegengesteuert werden aber an
dem punkt sind wir zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt in meiner einschätzung nicht
noch also ist so die omikron welle von
uns so gut beherrscht dass wir wenn wir
die booster impfung kampagnen etwas
beschleunigen könnten dem ganzen also
glaube ich herr werden können
ansonsten will ich dich danach fangen
aber aus jetziger sicht auch immer an
die drei herren reicht 2d oder zweige
plus dann aus also es gibt aus ihrer
sicht jetzt kein anlass schon eine stufe
höher zu schalten
also aus sicht der bundesregierung dann
aus meiner sicht somit ist das im moment
ausreichend was mir mehr sorgen macht
ist das 2g plus noch nicht überall
umgesetzt ist obwohl wir es beschlossen
haben und was mir auch sorge macht das
also die kontrollen zum teil nicht also
angemessen sind das ist zumindest meine
anekdotisch
so an evidenz das ist mein
eindruck den ich bekommen wir auch von
vielen gemeldet wird wir müssen stärker
werden im vollzug
und dann könnten wir viel erreichen aber
ich glaube dass wir mit durch das
maßnahmenpaket was sie beschlossen haben
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt das richtige
maßnahmenpaket am platz haben klöckner
vom handelsblatt fragt aber explizit
nach auch mit blick auf die mpk erhalten
sie also weitere maßnahmen nötig dass
man sie gerade beantwortet aber er fragt
oder gar lockerung
also lockerungen kann man zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt ausschließen wir sind mitten
in einer schweren welle mikrowelle und
wir können hier kein risiko eingehen ich
hätte es ganz genauso an wie ist
christian drosten gerade vorgetragen hat
dass wir halt eine große zahl von
ungeimpften älteren menschen haben zum
teil mit erheblichen risiko faktoren zum
teil nach krebserkrankungen wurde also
mit autoimmunerkrankungen noch mit
metabolischem syndrom und so weiter und
so fort also wir haben keinen anlass für
lockerungen
danke mit einer frage an herrn
lauterbach und auch an herrn drosten ich
würde sie gern bitte noch mal was zur
perspektive der kinder zu sagen die ja
gerade
in quarantäne sind und somit das
versprechen sozusagen kitas und schulen
bleiben offen ja nicht so ganz gehalten
werden kann wenn dann keiner hin gehen
darf sehen sie vor dem hintergrund der
omicron variante sozusagen also wie
bewerten sie die nikon variante mit
blick auf kinder und sind da vielleicht
dann doch auch perspektivisch noch
weitere lockerungen sachen quarantäne
möglich ich möchte kurz dazufügen die
frage von vor probleme von ansa
auch ein professor wieder ist omikron
die variante für kinder aggressiver sind
die verläufe mit
dieser mutation schwerer
wie viele kinder sind aktuell auf den
stationen und erwarten sie eine zunahme
der zahl zusammen beantworten
ja vielleicht fange ich an also die
datenlage zu kindern ist sehr schwierig
auszuwerten
zuerst gab es ja sehr beunruhigend daten
das also kinder schwerer erkranken
würden
es gab auch eine gewisse plausibilität
dafür ich lese die daten also
mittlerweile anders das ist so sagen
könnte dass kinder nicht schwere
erkrankung möglicherweise sogar leichter
erkranken und ich lese die daten im
moment auch so das ist nicht so ist dass
die omikron variante mehr viruslast auf
was somit könnte es sogar sein dass
kinder also in den schulen sich nicht so
stark infizieren wie mit stadtgarten
varianten das aber noch unklar ich weiß
ausdrücklich darauf hin dass unklar ist
das ist meine lesart der situation dass
wir auf jeden fall sehen dass auch
mikron sehr gut reagiert auf
schutzmaßnahmen wie zum beispiel masken
basteln spielen bei nikon variante aus
verschiedenen gründen eine große rolle
das hat auch damit zu tun dass so
genannte generation styles sehr kurz ist
das heißt die zeit in der jemand also
ansteckt und wird und dann ansteckend
ist und
werden es weiter stattfindet dann also
wirken also maßnahmen und kontakt
beschränkungen oder auch meinetwegen
masken tragen die würden dann sehr stark
das sind ja die maßnahmen in den
klassenräumen oft eine große rolle
spielen somit könnte es sein das wissen
wir aber zum jetzigen zeitpunkt nicht
genau was mit diesen klassischen
methoden maske tragen lüften zwischen
den schulstunden stoss wird zwischen den
schulstunden und also
also isolation der infizierten kinder
und vielleicht auch einer quarantäne die
sich begrenzt auf wenige kinder oder
tägliches testen sogar was wir durch die
schulen
lassen durch die schule welle
durchkommen ohne dass wir zuviel
schulausfall haben
schulschließungen dafür sehe ich zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt keinen anlass
ich kann das nur ergänzen in teilen also
tatsächlich ist die datenlage über die
krankheit schwerer bei kindern noch
eindeutig es gibt eine aktuelle arbeit
aus den usa die gerade kinder unter fünf
jahren betrachtet und nach dieser studie
sieht man milde verläufe ich werde aber
natürlich nur von den akuten
krankheitsfällen wir wissen ja nicht
genau wie langzeitfolgen von kuwait
auftreten gibt zum beispiel eine us
amerikanische studie glaubens letzte
oder vorletzte woche die das untersucht
hat wo man dann doch bestimmte risiken
für folgekrankheiten erkannt hat dass da
möchte ich einfach dass das nie
vergessen wird dass es eben auch dieses
long kurve der post gibt vor allem longo
witt
diskussion die die wir doch nicht
richtig fassen können aber ich möchte
man darauf hinweisen dass wir auch das
im kopf haben müssen wenn wir schwitzen
und warum wir schützen sollen kinder und
auch noch nummer ergänzen wichtig ist
wirklich das schlichtweg die maßnahmen
halt in den schulen auch angewendet wird
minister laut darauf sagt dass gerade
der vollzug diese anekdoten hören wir ja
alle dass eben bestimmte regeln nicht
vollzogen und kontrolliert werden und
das erschwert natürlich die kontrolle
des virus und in schulen es gibt ganz
klare empfehlungen es gibt sogar s3
leitlinien für schulen und die müssen
eben dann auch entsprechend umgesetzt
werden und dann kann man das auch im
griff haben
dann der nächste frage stelle rinke ja
danke schön herr
lauterbach sie haben eben auf die
priorisierung bei der pcr tests
hingewiesen jetzt gibt es ja kritik dass
deutschland im vergleich
internationalen vergleich begrenzte
laborkapazitäten und auch pcr
kapazitäten hat das vergesse ich ganz
gerne gefragt ob sie da ein manko sehen
bei dafür wie deutschland aufgestellt
ist und müsste man zb die kapazitäten
deutlich weiter ausreichend über die 2,6
millionen tests pro woche hinaus die im
moment zur verfügung stehen
im vergleich zu vielen anderen
europäischen ländern ist die kapazität
für pcr untersuchen in deutschland eher
hoch also wir haben hier aus meiner
sicht keinen mangel wir sind jetzt
natürlich in einer situation wo wir an
die volllast des systems antreten soweit
ich informiert bin ist die pcr
nutzung in
england mittlerweile eingestellt worden
so dass das dort also die bestätigende
also untersuchungen mit einer bisher
untersuchung gar nicht mehr durchgeführt
wird an dem punkt sind wir keineswegs es
wäre immer besseren mann mehr pcr
kapazität hätte aber die also welle
werden wir beherrschen können ich habe
in auftrag gegeben das die also antigen
tests die verfügbar sind in bezug auf
ihre
sensitivität für die omikron variante
untersucht werden wir wissen aus
stadtgarten
analysen die auch durch das paul ehrlich
institut bereits also veröffentlicht
worden sind und dass 80 prozent der anti
gen tests die auf dem markt sind die wir
empfehlen zertifizierte test
schätzungsweise auf der omicron
funktionieren wir wissen auch dass die
garantie gentests insbesondere in
späteren stadien der omicron infektion
besonders gut wirken in frühen phasen
wirken sie nicht ganz so gut was ich
daten auch sehr viel videomaterial in
der intakten zelle befindet wo der test
natürlich dann nicht so gut
funktionieren kann in so der bei der
sogenannten frei testung wird und die
anti gen test sehr gut wir haben auch
bereiche wo wir noch test einsparen
können ich glaube selbst was man also
bei der varianten verteilung die wird
jetzt hat in deutschland haben den so
genannten varianten pcr durchaus
kritisch sehen kann ob da noch also
notwendig ist zu mir ziehen zeiten damit
werden wir darüber reden wo wir also
einsparen können aber für diesen
besonders bedeutsamen bereich der
freiheit testung von medizinischen
pflegekräften ärzten ersten also auch
andere medizinischen personal mit dem
platz pca mit durch den grenzwert was
wir heute in der krone schutzmaßnahmen
ausnahmeverordnung geregelt haben dafür
haben wir genug pc aus und dafür habe
ich die priorisierung gestern abend
vorbereitet kurz danach frage stellen
weil sie das gerade erwähnt haben würde
ich die frage natürlich an der wieder
aufstellen sehen sie den verzicht auf
die
sequenzierung und die pca testung auf
virusvarianten auch als sinnvoll an im
moment
also es gibt ja den nationalen test
strategien gibt ja seit annähernd zwei
jahren kontinuierlich angepasst das sind
ja strategische ziele die man haben muss
also man darf nicht glauben nur wenn man
immer mehr irgendetwas tut dass dadurch
die situationsanalyse bessere wird wenn
man ganz viele verschiedene
möglichkeiten die schwere der pandemie
zu messen ich habe eben einige
aufgelistet und es gibt eine natürliche
kapazitätsgrenze und diese grenze wenn
die erreicht wird dann fokussiert man
und die fachleute wissen das auch und es
gibt entsprechende empfehlungen des
hauses und ja wenn man zb eine
hundertprozentige omikron welle hat also
wenn wirklich oregon gelder komplett
dann verdrängt haben wird dann wird es
in diesem moment natürlich nicht mehr so
wichtig sein so viele sequenzierung
durch das heißt dass alles was sie
beschreiben ist ja für fachleute 1 1 ein
tägliches handwerk dass sie alle
beherrschen und hier passen sogar die
nationale strategie kontinuierlich an
also das heißt diese ganzen art und
weise wie wir testen werden das wird
sich ändern wir wären ja auch irgendwann
wenn wir in der situation sind von der
christian drosten eben sprach wenn das
mal in dem ish ist dann wenn wir auch
natürlich deutlich weniger testen weil
wir dann einfach gar nicht mehr so ein
überblick haben müssen wenn wir nicht
diese akuten fällen haben also das test
verhalten der umgang mit dem ganzen
panini ändert sich kontinuierlich das
auch dass das schwierige natürlich zu
kommunizieren aber sie können glauben
dass die fachleute im wissen was dann zu
tun ist
der junge
zu impfpflicht kommen wieder können sie
mal aus ihrer sicht beschreiben was die
vorteile einer impfpflicht wehren und
herr drosten man sich auf die impflücken
angesprochen hatten im november gesagt
das ideal ziel müsse eine dreifach
komplett durch gamestar bevölkerung
seien wäre demnach eine impfpflicht
ideal
also zunächst mal das wichtige ist mir
was wirklich verstanden werden muss je
mehr menschen geimpft sind und je mehr
dann auch drei mal geimpft sind desto
besser kommen wir unser land das kommt
durch diese pandemie und desto mehr
schwere krankheiten verhindern wir und
desto mehr todesfälle verhindern wird
heißt also das ziel muss sein möglichst
hohe impfquoten jetzt ist dieser aspekt
schafft man das mit dem was wir momentan
tun wenn man die untersuchung von cosmo
anschaut dir gott sei dank seit märz
2020 immer wieder fragen stellen und
immer wieder einen einblick gibt auch
anderen versuchen aber die finde ich
jetzt ganz schön weil die eben schon so
lange läuft auch uns sehr wichtig ist
dann merkt man da steht drin dass die
menschen die sich jetzt nicht haben
impfen lassen dass viele von denen auch
sich nicht mehr impfen lassen wollen
also ich sag jetzt mal so die motiviert
man wahrscheinlich nicht mehr wir können
noch einige motivieren das heißt wir
müssen das wir müssen das angebot weiter
die barrieren senken wir müssen alles
tun also die die strategie die gefahren
wird mit postern ist genau richtig wir
müssen alles tun so viel wie möglich
anbieten
barrierenfreien aber offensichtlich
reicht dass er nicht das heißt also die
these ist dann mit einer impfpflicht
erreichen wir mehr und das was wenn das
stimmt diese these ich persönlich denke
dass das stimmt dass wir damit mehr
erreichen würden dann ist der vorteil
wir würden mehr impfen dann ist der
vorteil ganz einfach wir würden mit mir
impfungen mehr krankheiten verhindert
wir würden auch in gewissem maße die
transmission reduzieren man hat schon
einen schutz der infektion der schutz
vor infektionen ist nicht überragend
aber es ist immer noch einer da und ich
möchte auch noch mal darauf hinweisen
abgesehen von den ganzen für meine
begriffe der technokratischen
betrachtung dass wir das
gesundheitssystem entlasten und
krankenhäusern entlassen intensivstation
und wir hätten einfach mehr leben und
wir wir haben einfach mehr gesunde
menschen und ich möchte den letzten
update noch machen wenn wir mehr impfen
dann haben wir auch weniger kubik das
möchte ich immer wieder sagen wir wissen
noch nicht wie groß die krankheitslast
damit sein wird aber wir wissen dass es
wirklich sehr viele menschen sein werden
die darunter live und auch longo wird
können wir damit reduzieren es gibt doch
daten das pimps diese seltene
komplikation bei kindern das auch da
eine reduktion durch impfung ist also
insofern ist das ziel möglichst viel zu
impfen wenn es mit einer impfpflicht
erreicht wird ist das der richtige weg
ja ich glaube da muss ich gar nicht viel
zu fügen also für mich ist dieses thema
im pflicht und politisches thema ich
kann als virologe sagen dass wir
möglichst die diese lücke schließen
müssen im moment kann man natürlich
einfach nur mehr kraft auf das laufende
programm geben über den sommer wird man
sich eben überlegen müssen wie man den
herbst vorbereitet den winter
vorbereitet dass man bis dahin
diese impfquote weiter erhöht die
impflücken weiter schließt dass
möglichst viele leute das verstehen oder
ist einfach machen und da ist sicherlich
in pflicht eine der möglichkeiten
eine andere möglichkeit ist in
übermotivation und ansprache zu arbeiten
aber da scheinen die aussichten begrenzt
zu sein auch die medien könnten helfen
muss man hier vielleicht auch mal sagen
diese motivation und ansprache zu
verbessern einige wenige medien haben ja
über lange zeit in der vergangenheit
immer die darstellung auch propagiert
das ganze ist eigentlich harmlos und die
maßnahmen der politik das ist ja alles
total übertrieben auch das hat natürlich
dazu beigetragen dass viele leute dann
so in
einverständnis konflikt auch gekommen
sind also dass viele leute gedacht haben
na wenn das so ist das ist alles total
harmlos und andererseits sehe ich da
wird über impfpflicht geredet dann komme
ich in einen inneren verständnis
konflikt und
die folgen sehen wir glaube ich derzeit
in der gesellschaft und ich glaube es
wäre gut wenn die medien helfen würden
auch an dieser stelle wieder
korrekte informationen zu liefern
der bundestagsabgeordnete lothar wache
ist für eine impfpflicht vor der sich
aber der
bundesgesundheitsminister drückt und
keine eigenen vorschlag einbringen will
wo ist ihre führungsstärke lauterbach
eine provokante frage also erstmal der
bundesgesundheitsminister drückt sich
vor nichts und ist dafür auch
wahrscheinlich nicht bekannt aber was
ich also richtig finde ist dass ich mich
als
bundesgesundheitsminister
nicht offiziell zu dieser frage
ausgebrochen werden eben pflicht oder
nicht weil ich muss allen abgeordneten
mit meinem haus zu erwarten die anträge
vorbereiten anträge die eine
impfpflicht ablehnen eine anträge die
anleinpflicht ab 18 wollen anträge die
an ähnlichen ab 50 waren muss ja alle
unterstützen und das natürlich nicht
wenn ich gleichzeitig als minister also
alles einmal ans meinung habe das ist
also dann können wir uns auch das ganze
manöver von gruppen anträgen sparen wenn
die abgeordneten quasi also hier
von der regierung dann doch bevormundet
werden wie es gehen sollen das wäre dann
hätte der fahrer dann würden wir ja doch
dann also das ganze manöver dass man
also dass etliche anträge aus dem
parlament entscheiden dass das ganze
manöver könnten wir uns sparen wenn wir
als bundesregierung war sie eigene
anträge machen würde aber trotzdem also
als abgeordnete meine position noch mal
ganz klar sagen ich bin ohne wenn und
aber für eine impfpflicht ich bin für
eine impfpflicht ab 18 ich glaube dass
wir sonst also im herbst wieder vor
einer situation stehen die wir nicht
wollen ich glaube nicht dass die omikron
variante die letzte variante sein wird
das halte ich für fast ausgeschlossen
wir sehen jetzt schon wieder genetische
veränderungen in der delta variante mit
der bis vor kurzem gerungen haben die
vom serotyp her sehr weit von der oregon
variante entferntes christian rosner das
gerade sehr präzise dargestellt somit
also
würden wir im herbst wenn also wie kann
eben pflicht umsätzen vor soll vor der
situation stehen wir hätten dann wieder
an noch immer
bestehende große gruppe von gefährdeten
menschen die ungeimpft sind und einige
haben sogar ihren impfschutz den sie
hatten verloren weil eine neue variante
geist das wäre das wahrscheinlich
ergebnis und das also will ich als
abgeordneter uns mit
das will ich uns einfach ersparen das
will dann erneut vor der frage stehen
brauchen wir einen lock down wie kommen
wir können wirklich gut können wir den
schulbeginn wagen das muss ja nicht
unbedingt eine variante sein die so
harmlos verläuft wie wir uns das
wünschen ich hatte uns auch die omikron
variante nicht verharmlosen das noch mal
klar zu sagen das habe ich ja in fulda
zu leiten für die ungeimpften ist selbst
diese variante nicht harmlos wir können
aber eine variante bekommen diese
ansteckendes uns sehr viel gefährlicher
als das kann niemand ausschließen und
was wir wissen ist diejenigen die
grundimmunisierung sind und grund
immunisiert bedeutet das stimmig
christian posten zu dreifach geimpft
sind die sind vor schwerem verlauf
und tod
soweit wir sehen können für alle uns
bekannten
bestehenden varianten geschützt das
heißt wir werden dann in einer situation
wo wir dann kaum mehr menschen hätten
die so schwer erkranken würden und dass
sich schwer erkranken oder versterben
und diesen könnten wir dann
möglicherweise mit den uns zur verfügung
stehenden
medikamenten gut versorgen dann hätten
wir weniger schwere fälle und die
könnten wir auch noch medikamentös
versorgen ich glaube dass wir das machen
sollten ich glaube dass wir als
gesellschaft für die ungeimpften die
jetzt im risiko stehen sehr viel tun wir
geben viel auf selbst unsere kinder
gehen fiel auf wir gibt wir bringen
enorme mittel auf um die zu schützen
insbesondere die zu schützen die noch
ungeimpft sind wir können im gegenzug
aus meiner sicht von diesen menschen in
zukunft auch die impfung verlangen weil
die sendung ist fast nebenwirkungsfrei
und schützt vor schwerer krankheit so
dass wir unser normales
gesellschaftliches leben wieder
aufnehmen das ist meine persönliche
einschätzung und die trage ich auch in
aller klarheit vor ich bitte aber um
verständnis dass ich als
bundesgesundheitsminister also hier
nicht die gleiche position vortrag an
war da muss ich alle unterstützen und
tue das übrigens auch das wären ja im
hintergrund dieses anträge vorbereitet
ich muss alle unterstützen auch
diejenigen die anträge vor beraten mit
denen ich innerlich nicht übereinstimmen
zwei fragen an sie herr lauterbach karin
schirmer vom bayerischen rundfunk frage
in wie weit ist man vorbereitet auf die
zu erwartende hohe zahl an patienten in
den normalstation und notaufnahmen und
dazu passt die frage von karl
hinterleitner vom zdf der personalmangel
vor allem in der krankenhauspflege wird
uns gerade so eindrücklich wie nie vor
augen geführt mit welchen konkreten
maßnahmen werden sie im pflegenotstand
in den kliniken begegnen
6 für die kurzfristige also bewegung ist
ja das was ich eben vorgetragen habe
unser ziel unsere strategie wir haben ja
eine strategie wir versuchen hat die
steile hohe wand von omikron entweder in
einen hügel zu verwandeln oder die wand
zu verkürzen das ist das was wir machen
in beiden fällen hätten wir deutlich
weniger
krankenhausfälle sowohl auf der
normalstation wie auch auf der
intensivstation das heißt die maßnahmen
die wir ergriffen haben haben genau
dieses ziel das nicht das einzige 10
natürlich war wie auch schwere unfälle
verhindern wollen aber wir wollen auch
unser system so
belastbar lassen dass zu jedem zeitpunkt
eine notwendige krebsbehandlung oder
eine
behandlung einer koronaren herzkrankheit
möglich ist ohne qualitätsabstriche und
ohne zeit die verzögerung von dem was
wir bisher sehen vom erfolg unserer
maßnahmen
einschließlich der modellierungen die
versuchen das nach vorne zu rechnen
könnte das funktionieren wenn das
gefährdet wäre dann müssen wir wie eben
auch schon angedeutet dann müssen wir
zusätzliche maßnahmen ergreifen das wird
dann nicht anders möglich sein dann ist
der zeitpunkt gekommen wo zusätzliche
maßnahmen ergriffen werden müssen die
frage wie begegnen wir dem
pflegenotstand ich werde zunächst einmal
und das beseitigt den pflegenotstand
nicht dass es aber etwas was ich einfach
schnell machen möchte weil es sich
gehört weil es eine sache des anstands
ist ich möchte dass der pflege bonus so
schnell wie möglich jetzt verabschiedet
wird oder werden wir im januar noch
einen ersten entwurf werden wir also
vorlegen so dass das dann also im
parlament auch also diskutiert werden
kann und viel geboten das muss jetzt
kommen also warten zu lange schon darauf
zum zweiten also wir werden dann im
laufe der nächsten wochen und monate an
drei grundsätzlichen maßnahmen arbeiten
die für die bereitstellung der pflege
sehr wichtig sind zum einen also
welche rolle behalten die personal
untergrenzen ich bin sei es ein klarer
befürworter der personal untergrenzen
wie gehen wir mit zielwerten vor für die
personalausstattung in auf den stationen
stichpunkt ppa 2.0 das muss diskutiert
werden ob und wie wir das umsetzen und
zum dritten muss diskutiert werden wir
haben in der letzten legislaturperiode
beschlossen dass die pflege über das so
genannte selbst kostendeckungsprinzip
außerhalb der durch das ähnlich
administrierten die ag finanzierung
bezahlt wird das funktioniert aber nicht
so wie wir uns das damals gewünscht habe
und ich habe den koalitionsvertrag in
dieser hinsicht damals selbst verhandelt
dann war es daher relativ genau was
unsere wünsche gewesen sind das
funktioniert nicht so wie es
funktionieren soll daher müssen wir an
dieser zweimal
finanzierung der pflege für die
krankenhäuser müssen wir noch einmal
arbeiten wir müssen präzise an die
tatsächlichen kosten nach selbst
kostendeckungsprinzip herankommen und
das darf nicht verrechnet werden mit
anderen budget abteilungen mit anton
budget teilen so dass wir
nicht ein system haben wo qua gesetz
über das selbst kostendeckungsprinzip
abgerechnet wird aber es im prinzip dann
doch über umwege wieder in das
gesamtbudget hinein dass diese und diese
umgebungs kraisdorf für die möchte ich
stoppen das sind also drei maßnahmen die
wir hier verfolgen werden er drehte
frostig hatte eine frage an sie und zwar
die beschriebene wand von der lauter
nach der wahl führen diese sagen dass
die jetzt ergriffenen maßnahmen schon
ausreicht um diese wand zu verkleinern
oder eben diesen hügel daraus zu machen
oder hätten jetzt weiterer maßnahmen
durfte um das zu erreichen naja also ein
ganz guter indikator dass das was jetzt
im moment gemacht wird schon ziemlich
viel bewirkt ist dass die verdopplung
zeit in deutschland erheblich länger ist
als in anderen ländern also das kommt
nicht aus dem nichts also dennoch der
wert der im moment noch immer knapp über
1 das heißt ein kleines bisschen muss
man noch nach steuern es ist nur die
frage also es gibt klare daten die
eigentlich zeigen dass eine dreifache
impfung auch die übertragung verringert
und zwar sowohl bei der abgabe des virus
als auch bei der aufnahme des virus wenn
man sich infiziert und dreifach geimpft
ist da ist übrigens besonders deutlich
und jetzt erhöht man natürlich dass
durch die laufende booster kampagne
weiter und das mag schon sein dass das
diesen tick noch ausmacht
es ist aber im moment ganz schwer
abzuschätzen es läuft natürlich eine
sache dagegen das muss man sich auch
ganz ehrlich klar machen die schulen
sind jetzt wieder in betrieb gegangen
das könnte auch dafür sorgen dass es
wieder zunimmt und das muss man einfach
ganz genau beobachten im eigenen land
das können wir auch und die daten ist
nicht so schlecht wie immer gesagt wird
das kann man schon sehen und dann müsste
man eventuell auch nach regulieren
man kann auch in anderen ländern schauen
wo es ganz
effekte gibt also sondern beispielsweise
die haben im wirklichen wand gehabt mit
wenig maßnahmen und jetzt ist das sogar
ein bisschen von selbst zum stillstand
gekommen das ist so wenn das ebenso ganz
schnell hoch geht dann gibt es so
bestimmte effekte so netzwerkeffekte
beispielsweise gruppen effekte also wenn
in ihren kanten kreis alle das virus
hatten dann kriegen sie so schnell kein
zweites mal und das stellt sich dann
irgendwann ein und auch da können wir
das beobachten also da geht die inzidenz
jetzt eindeutig runter da wurden aber
jetzt auch natürlich die schulen wieder
geöffnet jetzt schauen wir mal in drei
wochen ob es dann wieder hochgeht oder
aus dem stabil bleibt also es gibt schon
sehr klare indikatoren die man anschauen
kann und ich glaube das ist einfach die
bessere antwort so eine frage auf so
eine frage dass man also dass man ja
nicht die zukunft voraussehen kann aber
dass man auch nicht komplett im
blindflug ist
normalerweise
ist das also
da müsste ich normalerweise die leute
fragen also die die anträge machen aber
wir arbeiten einer gruppe ganz
also konkret zu wir haben aber auch also
wie aus dem parlament anfragen bekommen
die also wahrscheinlich aus dem kreis
anderer gruppen gekommen sind um es mal
so auszudrücken
also einen antrag also scheint in
vorbereitung zu sein und da arbeiten wir
auch also helfen wir und also für einen
anderen antrag glaube ich sind es
einfach fragen die genutzt werden die
wir beantworten die dann helfen einen
solchen antrag zu entwickeln aber ich
bitte um verständnis dass ich natürlich
hier nicht also das sind vertrauliche
anfragen von parlamentariern ich kann
eigentlich sind die details gehen und
kann nicht sagen wer es ist und so
weiter und so fort ich nehme an dass
also sich hier sehr schnell gruppen
bilden werden noch öffentlich bekannt
sind und dann ist das ganze viel
einfacher zu handhaben es vermied das
war so bildet sich jetzt langsam
zusammen bietet sich erst langsam und in
der nächsten woche ist ja die
orientierungs debatte ich glaube dass
das ein sehr schneller an fahrt gewinnen
wird sonja alvarez von der
wirtschaftswoche fragt sie herr
lauterbach biontech kann den angepassten
omikron impfstoff schon im märz liefern
die er will aber erst im mai über die
zulassung entscheiden wie problematisch
ist diese verzögerung für die pandemie
bekämpfung und was passiert dann
eigentlich mit den dosen die ersten
generationen
also wir haben die verträge mit biontech
so gestaltet dass also für den fall dass
die der impfstoff sich verändert besser
angepasst ist also an dann aktuelle
varianten dass wir dann auch diesen
neuen impfstoff bekommen somit ist es
nicht so dass wir damit rechnen müssen
dass es einen riesigen vorwurf gibt oder
dass wir noch lange mit impfstoff
beliefert werden der gar nicht mehr
aktuell ist das ist nicht zu erwarten
und zum vorgehen der immer wir werden
sicherlich
das was wir tun
können über das paul-ehrlich-institut um
die
planungen der emea
zu begleiten muss man sozusagen das
werden wir tun also wir wünschen uns
natürlich die dass die immer relativ
schnell entscheidet gründlich und
schnell aber es wird kein politischer
druck ausgeübt ausgelegt aber das paul
ehrlich institut ist ja wenn man so wird
teil wie auch wir der emea und von daher
also werden wir im rahmen dessen was
medizinisch optimal und sicher ist
werden wir unser interesse an anderen
wirklich schnellen so lassen also werden
wir artikulieren und
sind uns aber dieser problematik bewusst
und entsprechende gespräche auch bei mir
im haus haben schon stattgefunden welche
möglichkeiten wieder ergreifen können
dann die nächste frau kollegin
angela mißlbeck vom ärzte
nachrichtendienst ja lauterbach sie
sagten vorhin die poster kampagne muss
noch beschleunigt werden
gleichzeitig sind vorgestern glaube ich
die mfa auf die straße gegangen und wir
erwarten eine welle die mit weniger
schweren erkrankungen einher geht das
deutet alles auf ziemliche belastungen
für die niedergelassenen für die
arztpraxen hin
die mfa martini beklagen dass sie immer
noch auf einen staatlichen bonus warten
und damit auch auf die politische
anerkennung welche rolle spielen denn
die arztpraxen in der aktuellen phase
der pandemie und ich irgend überlegungen
vielen dank
natürlich die gelegenheiten wurzeln
nicht erneut bei den ärztinnen und
ärzten bei den kollegen bedanken für die
also arbeit die geleistet wird also im
verbund wird den impfzentren ist die
poster kampagne die wir in deutschland
derzeit durchführen die erst spät
begonnen hat aber jetzt also sehr
schnell läuft sie ist in der
größenordnung und ich glaube auch mit
also diesem ehrgeizigen ziel in europa
einzigartig und das werden wir auch so
fortführen ich bin im austausch also mit
kassen in dieser sache so dass wir auch
noch einmal auf die kolleginnen und
kollegen zu gehen werden wir werden
nochmal versuchen das hohe tempo welches
bei der booster impfung gehabt haben vor
weihnachten zu erreichen der impfstoff
ist darüber habe ich eben also
aufgeklärt wir haben jetzt auch durch
eine beschaffung
rumänien 5 millionen zusätzliche dosen
bekommen wir haben es jetzt auch
geschafft also mit der stiko zusammen
eine klare impfempfehlungen für die
zwölf- bis 17-jährigen zu erwarten zu
erwirken somit glaube ich wird die
booster impfung kampagne noch einmal an
fahrt gewinnen dazu werden wir auch ein
eigenes format noch anderen machen wo
wir die öffentlichkeit
adressieren und ich glaube dass also
hier jede gelegenheit genutzt werden
muss
die also ersten und ärzte zu
unterstützen ich bringe in erinnerung
dass wir an über die feiertage auch bis
zum 9 januar die honorierung also für
die impfungen deutlich erhöht hat von 28
auf 36 euro wir werden also auch
bonussysteme werden wir einfach
nachdenken müssen die leistung der sind
es hier nicht nur anerkannt sondern es
ist notwendig und zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
finden ja mehr als 70 prozent der
impfungen in den praxen stadt das ist
eine großartige leistung und wir machen
uns gedanken über das verstetigen können
wie gesagt ich bin diesbezüglich mit
herrn gassen im regelmäßigen austausch
und wir sind für heute nachmittag in
dieser sache noch einmal für ein
gespräch sind wir verabredet
der kollege jordaans von api fragt nach
einem vorfall in sachsen herr lauterbach
während einer demo ginkgo oder maßnahmen
dresden am donnerstagabend haben
medizinstudenten vor der uniklinik in
der gegendemonstration gehalten die
polizei dorfen gegen mehr als 20
medizinstudenten
ordnungswidrigkeitsverfahren eingeleitet
was halten sie davon dass
medizinstudenten die sich für ihre
kollegen einsetzen von der polizei so
behandelt werden und haben sich schon
mit der sächsischen staatsregierung über
diesen fall gesprochen
ich kann diesen vorfall den bestürzenden
vorfall nicht sachkundig bewerten weil
mir einfach die information fehlt ich
kann nur so viel sagen wenn also
medizinstudentinnen und studieren
studenten sich dafür einsetzt dass sich
menschen impfen lassen und das also die
menschen die gefährdet sind so vor
schwerer krankheit und tod geschützt
werden dann findet dass man eine
ausdrückliche zustimmung
wie der ablauf jetzt der demonstration
gewesen ist ob es also wie genau die
also situationen sich dargestellt hat da
bitte ich einfach um verständnis das
kann ich aus der ferne kann ich das
nicht entsprechend einschätzen ich lasse
mich aber informieren
der kollege gut vom deutschlandfunk
fragt sie herr wieder in der gemeinsamen
presseinformation mit dem baby zu den
intensivstationen gestern schreibt das
el kaidas 9,6 prozent der kogit fälle
dort einen unvollständigen immunschutz
aufweisen sie nennen dabei teil
immunisierung also unverständlich
geimpft aber auch den status gewesen mit
welcher medizinischen begründung setzte
sie genesung mit unvollständigen
immunschutz gleich
ja das ist eine einschätzung die sich
aus der literatur lage ergibt das ist
eine eindeutige situation
diese wird auch von der stiko
entsprechend in ihre empfehlungen
aufgenommen und insofern ist das nichts
weiter als eine evidenzbasierte
einschätzung
dann eine frage noch an sie herr
lauterbach dann werden die apotheken
selbst erstmalig kurven 19 impfstoff
bestellen können gibt es hier ein
gesondertes kontingent für die apotheken
ein gesondertes kontingent haben wir
bisher nicht ausgewiesen es müssen ja
die voraussetzungen für die apotheken
erfüllt sein dass es aus meiner kenntnis
heraus jetzt der fall also dass also
apotheken bestellen können dass sie also
auch als leistungserbringer die impfung
durchführen können und dass sie auch so
dokumentieren können in das
entsprechende dokumentationssystem in
das seminar soweit ich informiert sind
alle drei voraussetzungen mittlerweile
erfüllt so dass ich davon ausgehe dass
die also impfungen in kürze beginnen
können ist so
hartmut berlinicke die zeitung herr
lauterbach ich habe den vorteil im final
und im
film ist in dieser diskussion also ich
meine damit die ungeimpfte ohne ausnahme
grund wahrscheinlich herr wähler weiß
wie viel denn diese leute also der
umgang des deutschen staates irgendwie
sehr höflich mit dieser menschengruppe
oder man wenn man sagen kann ist weil
ich also in österreich ab mitte märz
gibt es geld ist gefunden bis zu 3.600
vor diese menschen gruppe die ohne
ausnahme grund umkämpft sind wie sehen
sie das diese sache gibt es irgendwann
geldstrafe oder ein bisschen stärker
weil diese krise oper zieht sich mehr
und dann ich sterbe am intelligente
maske dankeschön
ich habe ja schon mal eine klare haltung
dargelegt dass ich ein befürworter einer
impfpflicht bin und ich glaube dass eine
impfpflicht uns hier weiter bringt würde
wenn wir jetzt also über die
impfwilligen
ich habe schlecht sprechen würden oder
wir würden also sie gering schätzen oder
abwertend das bringt uns ja nicht weiter
das bringt uns ja nicht dass verhärtete
nur die lage wenn man der meinung ist
dass eine impfpflicht
erforderlich ist
stichwort sonst kommen wir im herbst
wieder in eine ähnliche situation
sie ist geeignet so etwas also zu
beseitigen also die impfstoffe können
das in kombination mit medikamenten
adventon also geeignet und es ist auch
noch maßvoll war die impfung sehr sicher
ist und mittlerweile milliarden bis
jetzt wurden es wir wissen es gibt kaum
nebenwirkungen dann ergibt sich aus
diesem dreieck
es ist erforderlich
es ist geeignet und es ist maßvoll die
notwendigkeit zu handeln das ist meine
persönliche einschätzung
trotzdem also ich finde es nicht richtig
dass man also darüber spekuliert weshalb
leute sich nicht impfen lassen wollen
was man diese leute herabwürdigt ich
kenne auch leute sich nicht impfen
lassen wollen weil sie einfach dinge
nicht verstehen oder weil sie ganz
anderer meinung sind und 2000 fotos kann
alles akzeptiert werden das ist von mir
nicht so bewerten ich mache keine
unterschiede bei den gründen aber ich
mache schon ein unterschied wenn die
frage kommt ist derjenige der als
vorträgt in der pflicht sich impfen zu
lassen
das ist aus meiner sicht
einzusetzen
wie viel wie groß das lese der
menschengruppe die wollen nicht auf
keinen fall impfen lassen
ja also ganz aktuelle zahlen kenne ich
nicht aber wir gehen davon aus nach den
befragungen die ich im kopf habe vom
vorletzten jahr dass es etwa fünf
prozent verläuft sind der befolgung etwa
in diesem in diesem umfang ist das aber
die genaue zahl kann ich ihnen nicht
sagen
fünf minuten haben wir noch dann würde
ich gerne schluss machen damit wir hier
auch listen können herr besecke der
finanzsekretär n tv eine frage an alle
drei weil alle drei das thema anfangs
auch schon mal angerufen hatten bei den
prognosen dass wir uns ja in der
nächsten zeit vermutlich alle in
deutschland über kurz oder lang mit
umziehen werden warum ist es so wichtig
dass man die maßnahmen trotzdem
aufrechterhalten das nicht einfach
laufen lässt oder ganz kurz gefragt
warum macht es eben sehr wohl ein
unterschied ob ich mich heute oder erst
in vier oder sechs wochen inspizieren
na ja wir haben das ja im prinzip schon
von allen seiten beleuchtet diese fragen
also jetzt eine sehr steil
ansteigende inzidenz flanke führt dazu
dass ganz viele leute gleichzeitig krank
sind da ist es jetzt nicht unbedingt
wichtig ob die todkrank sind das reicht
das sie einfach sich nicht gut fühlen
zur arbeit gehen können natürlich dann
auch isolationsmaßnahmen unterliegen
nicht zur verfügung stehen als
arbeitskräfte das ist also so die die
eine überlegung dass dann also viele
bereiche im gesellschaftlichen leben in
probleme kommen
zum anderen ist es natürlich auch so
dass durch das abflachen dieses
incidents gipfels die medizinische
versorgung besser sichergestellt ist und
dann gibt es noch viele viele andere
gründe also beispielsweise wenn sie sich
vorstellen sie infizieren sich mit oder
ohne maske oder sagen wir mal trotz
maske dann ist das immer noch besser als
sich ohne maske infiziert zu haben weil
die virus dosis die sie dabei abkriegen
geringer ist und wir wissen inzwischen
ganz genau dass die virus dosis die
krankheit schwerer auch ganz stark
bestimmt also das sind dinge an die man
so im auf den ersten blick manchmal
nicht denkt aber das ist einfach
entscheidend und für die überlegung die
wir im moment haben wo stehen wir da das
ganze ist nicht so unähnlich wie im
frühjahr 2020 und tun nur mal so als
wüssten wir jetzt gar nichts davon dann
würde es auch zu einem extrem instanz
anstieg kommen inzwischen wissen wir
viel mehr das ist eine gute situation
wir wissen relativ gut auch wo wir
eigentlich maßnahmen brauchen um die
verbreitung zu verringern wo das sich
eher nicht so lohnt wir haben masken für
alle das ist auch sehr gut und man fragt
sich dann natürlich schon irgendwann
warum nutzt man denn dieses wissen dann
nicht um leben zu retten also ich glaube
das ist die einfache antwort darauf
ich will glauben dass es nicht stimmt
dass ich alle infiziert sind wir eine
relativ schwere bälle bekommen dann also
ist es oft so dass sich alle infizieren
sondern das wird ein teil der
bevölkerung nur sein und die geringer
teil ist desto besser und sagen das ist
ja nur eine frage eine frage der zeit
die gesamtzahl der leute die sich
infizieren denkt davon ab wie lang saß
wie langsam das anläuft weil wir wussten
ja gegen die infektion all diejenigen
die gebucht sind haben dann deutlich
reduziert das risiko sich überhaupt zu
infizieren das ist ja von anfang an
seiner ersten bundestagsrede als also
bundesminister ist das ja die strategie
dass wir also wenn sie uns jetzt zum
beispiel gelingen würde 80 prozent der
bevölkerung zu
also eben der bereits zweimal geimpften
also bevölkerung zu boostern oder noch
mehr da soll sich der kreis derer die
sich überhaupt infizieren können viel
geringer als werden die welle so schnell
durch läuft was das die brüstung
überhaupt keinen unterschied mehr machen
kann aber ich gebe überhaupt nicht davon
aus dass ich hier jeder infiziert dass
mich das will ich auf keinen verkaufen
und will kann auch noch mal gerne eine
sache wiederholen die wirklich uns allen
immer klar sein muss wir haben leider in
deutschland immer noch einen relevanten
anteil von mitbürgern und mitbürgerinnen
die sich nicht haben impfen lassen ja
die zahlen hatte herr drosten gerade
genannt man drei millionen etwa über 60
alleine ja das sind menschen die haben
aufgrund ihres alters ein erhöhtes
risiko schwer zu erkranken und
es ist ganz klar dass wenn wir sehr hohe
inzidenz haben dann ist eben die
möglichkeit dass auch solche menschen
infiziert werden einfach auch größer als
50 kleinen inzidenz nahmen wir haben
schlichtweg einen noch zu großen teile
unserer bevölkerung der nicht geimpftes
und die impfung schützt also das heißt
diese das boostern ist einer der
wichtigsten gründe um die zeit zu
gewinnen auch wir müssen mehr menschen
bewusst sein und impfen wir haben
einfach in deutschland einen großen
anteil die immer noch nicht geimpft und
gepustet sind also dann doch hessen
bitte um kurze fragen und kurze
antworten welche umsetzung beschlossener
maßnahmen
lauterbach ministerpräsident haseloff
hat gesagt in sachsen-anhalt müsse zweig
plus nicht umgesetzt werden weil dort
omikron quasi nicht existent sei sondern
nur delta was bedeutet ein solcher
ausstieg aus gemeinsam beschlossenen
forderungen und herr wieder herr droste
nicht evidenz dafür dass tatsächlich
omikron sozusagen einen bogen um sachsen
anhalt macht
also ich kann das so kurz machen ich
hätte mir natürlich gewünscht
wenn wir die 2g plus regelung überall
umgesetzt hätten und
dass daher
auf der anderen seite ist es so ich habe
heute im bundesrat in meiner rede noch
einmal auf hingewiesen dass wir nur
erfolgreich sind wenn wir die regeln die
wir beschlossen haben nicht nur eins zu
eins umsetzen sondern auch den vollzug
kontrollieren und das system was wir
haben mit der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz der
bundesregierung ist ein system was gut
funktioniert ist passiert aber darauf
dass man sich aufeinander verlassen kann
und dazu zählt auch dass die dinge
umgesetzt worden
die dinge umgesetzt werden die bereits
geschlossen worden
also nach den uns vorliegenden
informationen und der ausbreitung von
omikron gehen wir davon aus dass in ganz
deutschland in relativ kurzer zeit um
conti dominierende variante sein wird
und delta
sehr stark verdrängen wird
eine kurze frage nur noch zu den
sogenannten food impfstoffen was glauben
sie herr minister wie sehr diese
impfstoffe die jetzt abbekommen ich will
mithelfen können zu schließen oder ist
das nicht signifikant am ende und was
sind die genauen lieferdaten damit die
darauf warten sich etwas drauf
einstellen können ja vielen dank das
wird der erste impfstoff der also ein
quasi tot im stoff ist von nowaks wird
auf der grundlage von liefer angaben die
wir gestern also vom hersteller haben
bekommen können hat dem 21 10 zweiten
verfügbar sein in zunächst einmal einer
größenordnung von
1,75 millionen dosen sind dann weitere
325 millionen dosen
gekauft und werden geliefert ich kann
aber nicht genau sagen wann die
geliefert werden ich hoffe dann auch
noch in der letzten
februarwoche aber die impfung könnte
somit also ab der dritten februarwoche
vorsichtig beginnen im günstigsten fall
wir versuchen die lieferung zu
beschleunigen wir arbeiten mit dem
unternehmen sehr eng zusammen ich selbst
kann die wertigkeit des impfstoffes für
die omikron variante nicht gut
einschätzen
die variante hat ursprünglich war weil
der impfstoff ursprünglich bei einer
anderen variante getestet worden ist ich
hoffe aber und kann auch von außen aus
dem stoff hier gut wirken wird weil wir
wissen dass er bei einer anderen
variante in der vergangenheit auch ganz
gut gewirkt hat ebenfalls einen hohen
escape anteil gehabt hat und daher
glaube ich wird der impfstoff uns hier
weiter bringen und ganz klar ist also
das seien eben stoff den wir auch
empfehlen werden und der wird denjenigen
besonderes zur verfügung stehen die
diese art der impfung bevorzugen
da legen wir keine daten vor und daher
kann ich das nicht beantworten
dann sind wir heute durch ich habe nicht
alle fragen im saal geschafft auch nicht
alle fragen online das tut mir leid aber
jetzt müssen wir schluss machen um zu
lüften ich bedanke mich ganz herzlich
bei herrn lauterbach
dankeschön und da geschossen
und wir sagen auch danke das thema
bleibt uns erhalten deutschland steht so
sagt das lka am beginn der fünften welle
es liegt ein bisschen an uns so sagte
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach ob
das eine große wand oder